[Musique]
c'est un nouveau jeu je vous explique
c'est très simple je vais poser C
questions sur la vie de Karine Le
Marchand au chroniqueur donc je vais les
choisir à chaque fois il y aura donc les
chroniqueurs d'un côté Karine Le
Marchand de l'autre s'il répondent bien
ils auront un point s'il répondent mal
c'est Karine qui aura le point à la fin
des C questions si les
chroniqueurs perdent face à Karine
Karine devra non c'est un des
chroniqueurs qui devra faire un gage qui
devra donc faire un petit gage c'est il
faudra chanter beautiful mais d'une
manière un petit peu particulière vous
allez voir si vous donnez des bonnes
réponses et que vous battez Carine c'est
Carine dev je vous dis vous allez devoir
chanter your beautiful de James BL avec
un petit truc en plus mais c'est rien de
grave voilà ça va en plus vous avez de
beaux pieds vous allez comprendre tout à
l'heure pour le moment voici la première
question je la pose à jeanluc Lemoine
dans sa voiture Karine Le Marchand
laisse toujours dans son V poche un ASP
venin une pilote de secours un CD de
James blund ou une bombe larymogène
alors ah je la je la sens hypocondrique
alors un aspi venin un aspi venin et
bien c'est une bonne réponse de Jean-Luc
Lemoine elle a bien un aspi
venin ouais quoi vous avez un aspiv
venin bah oui mais c'est pour ma fille
c'est il y a des gens qui meurent parce
qu'ils font des des chocs
anaphylactiques si on n pas ça il a j'ai
mais j'ai a j'ai aussi un kit de secours
pour faire du bouche à
bouche elle a également et vous avez une
culotte aussi ou ou oui mais elle a pas
dans sa voiture elle a également une
bombe lacrimogène mais ça c'est pour
Christophe carrière au cas où attention
donc un point pour les chroniqueur
attention question pour Isabelle
mainiibosque quelle est l'une des
passions de Karine Le Marchand
participer à des rassemblements de
voitures tuning regarder des films de
lifting ou de lipossution appeler
Stéphane Plaza à 4h du matin et
raccrocher ou faire de la peinture sur
des corps dénudés allez 3 secondes
j'aurais bien dit appel Stéphan pleazza
4h du matin il raccrocher même si c'est
pas vrai sinon c'est votre réponse ils
sont très copains oui oui mercii C he
elle elle a compris toutes les questions
c'est magnifique alors non c'est pas
appelé Stéphane pazza 4h du matin c'est
quoi la bonne réponse Karine elle est
pas exactement là c'est quoi c'est c'est
filmer des films de lifting et les
position mais c'est quoi cette histoire
vous fait quoi non mais c'est vrai vous
fait j'ai j'ai des copains qui sont
chirurgien esthétiqu moi je suis
fascinée par la chirurg esthétique je
trouve ça en la chirurgie en général ou
et et donc je je bon maintenant c'est
plus compliqué mais je me faisais passer
pour une assistante et j'allais filmer
des j'ai des cassettes chez moi de
lifting
notamment un point un point partout
attention question pour Gill verdz de
qui était amoureuse Karine quand elle
était petite Jean-Pierre foucot Patrick
Sébastien Jean-Jacques Goldman ou
Casimir Jean-Pierre foucot Patrick
Casimir alors je vais dire Jean-Jacques
Goldman Jean-Jacques Goldman est-ce que
c'est vrai Karine bah comme beaucoup non
et oui c'est une bonne réponse de Gill
Verdes 2 pour les
TR attention question pour Thierry Morau
quel exploit sportif Karine l mararchand
a-t-elle réussi récemment elle a plongé
en apné à plus de 35 m elle a couru le
Marathon de Paris elle a obtenu sa
ceinture noire de taekwendo où elle a
sauté 19 fois dans un slip en 30
secondes elle a couru le Maron par ré
oui elle a couru le Marathon de Paris
exactement l'année dernière
Karim il y a donc 3.1 pour les
chroniqueurs il y av beaucoup de bonnes
réponses là Karine non mais je rigolais
pour sauter dans un slip vousz vous avez
jamais essayé de sauter dans un slep oui
je le fais tout le temps c'est vraiment
c'est ma passion non si vous voulez
passer à la maison on fera ensemble je
peux vous dire j'invite plein d'amis à
le faire on s'éclate Julien est venu une
fois je suis venu dimanche dernier ah
ouais il l' fait 14 fois je TASS régalé
et bien Karine j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle vous avez perdu Karine Le
Marchand les chronqueurs on gagné
applaudissement pour eux merci en régie
ils sont
fatigués kine je vous le
dis donc dans un
instant d'ailleurs on peut le faire tout
de suite Karine Le Marchand va devoir
chanter your beautiful mais vous allez
avoir une chèvre qui va venir et qui va
vous lécher les pieds pendant que vous
chantez d'accord faites rentrer la
chèvre s'il vous plaît
allez carineine venez vous asseoir venez
là
venez vous avez la crue la j'ai des
pieds hyper moches mais non vous avez
des pieds magnifi mais pas du tout j'ai
un aluxalgus au pied gauche il faut que
je fasse Algus alors je vous donne le
pied droit faites le pied droit vous
inquiétez pas la la chèvre bonjour ma
chérie comment elle s'appelle la
chèvreig neige ah ah qu'est-ce qui se
passe il y a un mec qui siffle c'est
quoi c'est qui c'est qui c'est vous du
sel ou il y un mec dans le public qui
fait plaisir alors tenez ça c'est votre
gamelle non c'est B alors donc qu'est-ce
que je fais avec ça ah oui je vous
badigeonner le pied avec du sel elle
s'appelle neige donc avec exactement
alors attention on y va je peux avir
votre pied Carine s'il PL chatouilleuse
ah oui non c'est vrai ah moii j'ai pas
des beaux pieds mais ça Vaz on va pas
filmer les pieds mettez-vous comme ça
c'est sur la plante c'est ça qu'on veut
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut
voilà
voilà vas-y ma chérie alors allez-y on
commence à chanter elle veut pas allez-y
elle veut pas vas-y ma chérie vas-y ma
[Musique]
chérie faut
chanter on a un problème de chè elle
veut pas s'attaquer au
pi les gars les gars attendez on va
arrêter de secondes on est en direct
bien s je
l christop carre dis je lche les
[Applaudissements]
pieds
ri rien
vous devez pas accep
çaarine c'est rien on remplace juste une
chef par un
mouton la chvre elle vous lèche quoi
quoi plus rien lcher la est venelle
estpa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Alley vraiment le faire vous oui bien
sûr non mais il est complè vous avez
fait des études mais c'est un malade
vous avez une image votre enfant vous
regardei plus personne regarde la
condition masculine c'est un combat
maintenant très beau
pied il sa plus quoi faire pour vous
P moi jeis vous dire moi vous faites ce
que vous voulez parceprès on va dire que
je
vous crois
la
mais y rien allez faites vous voulezire
allez vas-y chante non mais attendez non
mais non c'est pas regardez et vous ça
vous choque mais non mais arrête pas ça
non mais non arrête arrête c'est
fou ça
malade Carine allez c'est bon c'est bon
merci venez Karine oh là là mais quel
malade e mais il est dégueulasse non
mais franchement chroniqueurs deviennent
vraiment fou non mais il y en a qu'un
qui fait ouais bravo c'est Gill ver il
est complètement il est tout content lui
c'est l'amour mon ami c'est l'amour il
dit non mais le mec ne sait plus quoi
faire quoi c'est un malade monn
prochaine il sera dans le classement du
JDD ça c'est sûr c'est magnifique mais
j'arve vousz vu ce qu'il a fait c'est la
première fois qu'on vouschz les pied un
homme oui parce que c'est pas mon c'est
pas mon point le plus sensible ah oui
c'est vrai ou c'est dommage par que lui
spécialité une émission familiale car
ouais non mais mais c'est vrai ben bravo
en tout cas Christophe carrierre qui a
fait les risques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]